you know we'll all sit down but I don't
know you know it's you know all you need
to stand up and sit down for a second
it's kind of cold in here and give you
all of you know what is it the seventh
inning break or something this is not LA
yeah is this because we're Canadian okay
all right we can see so yeah I'm really
you know what fun to have Chris CEO of
Evernote and Tim had a vent vp of
engineering at snap and you guys still
have a bit in common snap has a hundred
million active users at least I'm pretty
well polish number was 150 but okay see
we think maybe more um and then you have
your very popular application with our
service with 200 million and um I guess
you're both just like our previous
speaker Canucks yes yes yes you are
below that will try to keep earth will
try to try to keep the gloves on and
we'll keep the hockey references to a
minimum okay but you have to forgive us
if we disappear so Canada's playing in
the world cup of hockey later tonight
hell and I yeah all right against Europe
and if if we don't watch it i think the
canadian government might revoke our
passports so okay so so you two have
taken different paths to the cloud ever
know was on prem you're just starting to
move to the cloud yeah when you arrived
at snapchat it was running on Google App
Engine absolutely and you you've built
systems both on-premise and in the cloud
what have you found about working in the
cloud that's different do you this it
better is it worth sure the answer the
last question first I think it's
unquestionably better I like to tell a
story about when I arrived a snapchat
and so I i joined I'm employee 18 when I
started there my engineering team was
ten
the most experienced engineer on the
team had three years of engineering
experience the application was doing
thinking yeah yeah fresh thinking yeah
so the the application is doing between
200 and 300 thousand queries per second
to the back end not a single one of
those people carried a pager so they
just assumed it would work and we were
having five five percent week-over-week
growth and so and Google was chugging
along in the background now I'm not I'm
not going to pretend there weren't
problems we we spend it once I got there
I spent a year working with Google to
kind of optimized and get better but I
was certainly not the application wasn't
down all the time you you know you think
back to the early days of Twitter's
hyper growth and fail that everyone was
would joke about fail whales we just
kind of those and so I apologize to
anyone into it but from Twitter in the
audience and if there is one honey one
thought so yeah yeah you told me I think
when I met you in January that you had
16 systems peoples I had no I so the so
I had I had no offer i had 10 people and
I operated the service myself i would i
would give it only said i would i would
page myself whenever went down and then
i would cut ticket to google and we'd
work together to fix it my friend my
friend and colleague from amazon aaron
joined me and then we would do it
together the two of us until about April
or May so for about the first eight
months we I was that snapchat I was the
lone operator and vp of engineering yeah
we're still laughing um Chris you you
actually came from google you kind of i
know you value our technology you value
our innovation what is the technical
innovation that you're looking for from
google yeah so I've been at Evernote
just over a year and the first
observation was you know we were trying
to do too many things and in this
I don't care what scale you're right you
have to do a few things into them world
class like we operate in every country
in the world so we really just did a
hard assessment like what things are we
going to really double down on and what
things are going to not and operating a
physical you know data center just was
clearly not something we wanted to
differentiate around so once we'd made
that decision we asked ourselves a
couple questions maybe three we said
okay like what's the next three to five
years hold in terms of a computing
platform who's the best in the world at
that and then three perhaps most
importantly what are the capabilities
that we need to really really
meaningfully differentiate and really
deliver value for our users first two
were relatively straightforward AI and
machine learning are the next computing
platform there's no question in our
minds and I'm a little biased perhaps
from spending some time at Google but
Google clearly is the leader in terms of
AI in machine learning at scale the
third question was about what
capabilities can we do we need to marry
with the users data that they trust with
us right we have five billion notes and
five billion more attachments like this
is people's very private narrative of
their life so how do we combine that
information with ml essentially to
unlock some real user experiences and
know when we like to say our mission is
to unlock the potential of ideas so
really that's about removing all
friction so step one for us was boys a
very practical implication I think we've
hit a tipping point when it comes to
voice and google has CIGNA's own
disclosed twenty percent of search has
come through voice so we really want to
capture capture ideas at the speed at
which people come up with them so voice
is one big bet for us and we really want
to we're really excited about the NLP
progress that you guys have made so we
think that's one logical intersection
and then once people put information
these ideas into Evernote it's a very
manual process for organizing today and
we think that the power of what we saw
this a little bit about that powers
google photos for example will really
help users as I say organize without
early organizing it's kind of like going
you know getting a six pack without
going to the gym right we can combine
that technology to help people organize
their content and then last but not
least is search or retrieval really want
to help people circus the information
that they put in Evernote at just the
right time so when we thought about
who's the leader and who can
help us with capabilities it was kind of
a no-brainer in the end and then in you
frankly we're an intangible well because
you're committed to it and it was clear
like when we actually did look at the
intangible decision factors it was not
even close in terms of your ability and
your desire to win in this game even
though you're coming from a slight
slight disadvantage in terms of when you
started yeah I mean you're sort of both
talking about something kind of
interesting which is that you know your
sort of you were for a long as time when
you build a company you had to build
absolutely everything yourself we didn't
have a choice and ten years ago there
was no play no a of us right so now all
of a sudden you're going wait a minute
we don't have to build everything
ourselves and and then look at all the
things you want to take advantage of and
these Stanford undergrads didn't even
occur to them to build everything
themselves they took the passive path of
least resistance yeah frankly for me
it's about focus right I think that's
what he's talking about i think you when
you don't have to worry about
infrastructure and you don't have to
worry about is that rack gonna land in
your on the front doors of your data
center so you can show your network
engineer can cable it up and you can
focus on innovating on product you end
up with just spending more of your your
own cycles and your team cycles on
innovation which is what i think where
you end up winning in the end they're
winning because of speed i think and it
is not just because of you know the
selfies and photos it's actually because
you guys are really innovating with
product right if you if you really ask
yourself who's who's pushing out product
the highest quality in that in that game
it's you know snap and we're proud of
that and we know a lot of that to google
cloud honestly and have for the last
three years that we would not be able to
do what we've been able to do without
google cloud and our site reliability
engineers love you guys it's a love-hate
relationship i think they pay attention
right yeah they absolutely pay attention
if you were to kind of look back to i
mean with all that experience
you were your younger self is there any
advice if you were just moving to the
cloud or doing things differently you
know one of the things I've really
learned is managed services make a big
difference so and it depending on how
much state is preserved is dictates my
desire for how managed I want them to be
so for a service where i want data large
amounts of data to live forever i want i
prefer that to be as managed as i can
and as i move up through the caching
layer and into the serving layer i'm
willing to tolerate less and less
managed or less and less management of
the service services because it becomes
easier as an engineer to do that and and
so I would get I would I would reinforce
that to my my younger self and there's
you know it I think it's it's it's
tempting as an engineer to want to
control your own destiny and take
matters into your own hands and know
exactly how your replication is working
and and and it takes a little bit of
courage to let that go and tell that
give that to someone else and say and
just sort of trust that the data storage
provider or the front end service
provider will will will be able to take
care of that for you and take care of it
better than you can do possibly do it
yourself and so just lean into that
again like this option wasn't available
ten years ago you had to do it all
yourself and so it exists now and the
companies that are going to be able to
move fast and execute and when I think
are going to be the companies that take
advantage of that advantage and who
would have thought that a camera company
like Snap would need this infrastructure
I was hoping you would wear some
spectacles today not unveiled yet so the
will stay tuned next few weeks maybe
find a paradigm and what about ever know
what's next for ever known over the next
few years yeah so it's been a great
great year we've really invested in a
bunch of different areas
Merrilee the team so I fundamentally
believe the team you build is the
company you build and like the best team
wins best thing you've made huge
progress in the last year yeah yeah so
it's been great and we've also invested
significantly in the technical platform
right now gcp is a big part of that of
course but there are many other things
under the hood that we've done and we're
just so thrilled to start unleashing on
a kind of regular cadence stuff that
people will start to see I use the
metaphor of an iceberg sometimes that a
lot of what we've been doing has been
below the water so but you know whether
it's our search technology are editing
or our sync technology these are all new
things so people are going to start to
see those things in the coming coming
weeks and our users are really excited
in the early test I think more more
strategically we look out a couple more
years we've been a great single-player
product and we really find and there's
appetite for us to help impact teams so
nothing great in the world happens
without teams and you saw a great
announcement from you guys like we
believe in that future too so how do we
make that that migration it is a fifth
of our business today without actually
investing very heavily in that so you
can expect us to to do that and I think
that's another part of the decision
factor for us to was when you try to go
win in the workplace the stakes are
higher the stakes are higher in terms of
security in terms of compliance and all
these other things and a lot of those
things will come as a as an added bonus
for us so we don't have to again think
about all those features you guys can
help us with that but we really want to
win in the workplace and really help I
think team leader you probably want to
help you we want to work with you with
apps i do think tim cares about privacy
and security absolutely but yes
absolutely we'll all the stakes the
access controls get more complicated in
the enterprise that's for sure I do
thanks Tim thanks Chris thank you very
much thank you Dad appreciate okay